sadia chaudhary joins me now from
outside the high court in central london
uh morning sadia this was not the news
that archie battersby's parents were
hoping for
no it is devastating news for arch's
family they have lost their bid at the
high court to have him moved into a
hospice where they had wanted
him to be when his life support
treatment is withdrawn
that case was heard here yesterday the
family had said that moving him to a
hospice would give him dignity the trust
the hospital trust which is bart's
health nhs trust which is treating
archie said it was in his best interest
for the treatment withdrawal to happen
at the royal london hospital where he
currently is and where he has been for
about 120 days now it came after the
family had lost all of their legal roots
to have that treatment continue earlier
in the week bart's health nhs trusts are
under a
high court order to end that treatment
they say that they need to do it quickly
in order to not breach that order that
high court or their previous high court
order they had given the family until
9am yesterday to file an application to
the high court
in order to
to try and move him to a hospice and the
trust had said that if that application
wasn't made by 9am then it would proceed
with
removing treatment
at 11am that was yesterday the family
did file that application we understand
right at the last minute um which then
uh proceeded to a long and unusual day
in court we arrived here at 3 30 and
didn't leave until about quarter to
eleven
this morning when we spoke to holly she
said she'd had a very holly dance that's
archie's mother she said she'd had a
very difficult
night and after the
judgment came down she described it as
sick and outrageous to spiny as she told
us that she plans to appeal
now the trust have said the latest thing
that we heard from the trust is that
they will not
withdraw treatment until all outstanding
legal issues are resolved and just a
reminder that this was a the 10th
court proceeding that the family have
gone through i think they've made about
16 or 17 appearances in court they have
lost all but one of those including
today's one and judge these here at the
high court ruled that after hearing
lots of medical evidence about the
process in which archie would be moved
to a hospice the risk of him dying on
route in transit she said was
so high and therefore the family's bid
for archie to be moved to a hospice
today has been denied
yeah the worst possible news for his
family there
what are the legal avenues still open to
them sadia
holly dance archer's mother has today
told sky news that she plans to appeal
uh we don't know if that appeal will be
granted so we don't know but she she
definitely does say that she she plans
to appeal this has been a very long
process for her she's uh
and the family they have been through
ten different court proceedings it
started here at the high quarter you
know in may when the proceedings were
about whether or not archery should have
a brain stem test it culminated uh
earlier this week into an international
affair un involvement and the european
court of human rights saying that it
couldn't interfere in brit matters of
british courts of national courts we've
seen this case go to the high court now
four times to the court of appeal three
times and the supreme court which is
britain's highest appeals court twice
and as i say she has lost holy dance and
the archie battersby's family have lost
all but one of those
she doesn't seem hopeful that she will
get anywhere but she did say to us this
morning that she plans to appeal
all right sadia chaudhary they're
bringing us the breaking news that the
family of archie battersby has lost in
their high court bid
to allow him to transfer to a hospice
from the royal london hospital where he
is currently receiving life support
treatment